[Music]
in a skip joke button news submitted by
mr. Devlin Seth Meyers is new Netflix
special lets you skip the Trump jokes
that's funny
oh so there's like a skip intro but
another the skip skip joke but really
intelligent engineering yeah they get -
yep so for those of you don't know this
is Seth Meyers
he's a late-night show would you also
like the head writer a VESA note yeah I
think it might be he's the best whoever
did the Weekend Update thing other than
Norm Macdonald oh he's a [ __ ] great
writer hmm yeah
so he he's gonna come out with this new
special called lobby baby that debuts on
Netflix and there's this so he thought
about how there is a skip intro button
and like the fact that the platform he's
gonna be having this special on so he
thought that'd be kind of cool he says
it dawned on me that because it was on
Netflix there would be this opportunity
to put to put an technology that would
allow people to skip Trump jokes it was
a way to build in the response to anyone
who would say oh let me guess there's
gonna be jokes about the president but
he thinks that people are not really
gonna use it that it's just kind of like
it the fact that it's there for the joke
yeah yeah it's funny yeah so people are
like oh that's kind of cool I mean also
it is kind of funny because it's like
political stuff like people get tired of
all that so he tries a catering to
Republicans - trying to get Republicans
to watch a show I think he's just
[ __ ] around yeah my saying goodbye
listen skip this part when I was a kid I
[ __ ] I watched every late-night show
always and I I remember what every night
is the same [ __ ] Clinton jokes Monica
Lewinsky jerking off on a dress like
he's [ __ ] everybody basically and
it's the same [ __ ] with Trump jokes he's
orange he's fat he's really into himself
so it's like it's just this I'm like
please let's skip it cuz it's the same
[ __ ] bit every time it just gets
hacky at a certain point I mean I just
like not I just wish I could skip him
all day anyway
and I'm not thinking about him jokes are
not I just don't want him in my life no
sew that button we're freezing there you
go those are buck caters to all
demographics and walks of life I wanna
see Donald Trump do stand-up Tommy
he does it every day I know he does
that's why I just recently I was on
Twitter and whenever I see anything
Trump or anything politics I'm always
like on board skipping it like I just
scroll past it on my feed but there was
this one clip that was kind of funny
because he was he was doing like a rally
somewhere I think Kentucky or something
hands up saying something like like hood
don't don't make me lose I don't make me
look bad cuz you're gonna be looking bad
too or something like he got really
desperate and it was kind of funny cuz
I'm like damn doing really desperate I
think it's a bit though look I know that
God whatever it's just that [ __ ]
everybody takes him so seriously all the
[ __ ] time and it's like dude half the
time he's an entertainer before
president just [ __ ] around yes of
course but every but it's just it
depends on who you are and how seriously
you take everything yeah do you think
when he hugged that guy on the Nationals
baseball team like it was from the
Titanic juicy is he like this guy put on
the maggot hat and so he goes up behind
just as such he doesn't had a human he's
behind his baseball player and he hugs
him like this and he's like oh that was
weird he like literally what the [ __ ]
but his arms behind like if like Tiff's
foot your arms out where he hugged it
from the back yes he goes hug her it was
like it's like he doesn't know how do
human was he hugging from the back cuz
he was behind him at the moment she's
like at a podium he just hugged a guy
that's I'm saying when you take it all
very serious I think see that's evidence
he's not even human person but I'm like
he's just hugging a [ __ ] guy I think
you know exactly where the camera is and
he goes I'm gonna hug the weirdest
[ __ ] way possible it's like when you
put the candy bar on the kids the
trick-or-treaters head do you see that
this is the lack of sleep no it's
everyone's personal bias goes into it
right like I see everything as a big bed
as a
[ __ ] seriously but then if somebody
already is predisposed to feel away then
they're like I'll see it's all another
weird thing another you mean it's just
that's how we all are though we all have
our personal biases and we inject them
into [ __ ] everything I'm nice over
here watching home decor videos yeah I
think people see the president and
they're just like well it's a serious
role cuz he's like controlling or not
controlling maybe but the whole country
so he shouldn't be doing weird [ __ ] like
that like he should be a little bit more
serious your presidents are weird by
trade true they're [ __ ] strange
people who are like I should run
everything true like so it's just to me
I know I don't know I remember when
everyone hated Obama too like and it's
the same kind of [ __ ] where I see it all
and I just go how can you take any of
this [ __ ] that's seriously like I
remember people being like how could you
go on comedians on cars or he went on
Bear Grylls a show and [ __ ] Obama that's
the president you got the president I'll
[ __ ] bear grylls shouldn't you have
more important [ __ ] to do and I'm like
like what [ __ ] blowing up every
country in the world like just at least
he's [ __ ] chilling like I don't know
everyone takes everything so serious
yeah I mean I don't know I wish like I
said this before but I wish it would be
like a Chrome extension where it's like
just don't hide all politics stuff for
me cuz I'm one of those people are like
it's okay yeah I'm good
I feel like I don't have control over it
anyway so when people get all riled up
or like you know I I can vote that's
about it like yeah so I feel very like
there's nothing I can do about this in
this moment can we just watch you study
the cheat sheet
yeah for sure okay like I watch like
certain commentary videos on it people
with like neutral positions and like
them breaking it down but I won't like
everyday bro to like me and like get
inundated with things I can't control I
don't like it of culture I enjoy anger I
enjoy getting angry is one of my
favorite things for me because they are
watching other angry people no no if I
could get angry at something that
inspires like a bid or something for me
or like an angle or like a satirical
[ __ ] thing oh so I can't wait usually
for those things you try to find things
that piss you off a little bit yes very
much I like to find kitties that try
jumps places they fall you would love
dick tock
yeah I'm subscribed to the New York
Times and every day they're sending me
an email of the impeachment brief like
like what's happening right now with the
whole impeachment
well I feel like every month there's
like a new thing that everyone's like
raging about and nothing ever happens or
changes or anything it's just like the
same anyway cuz it's like oh here's the
law okay well I guess that means that
the right things gonna happen cuz that's
the law oh no actually we can just
ignore the subpoena or we can do
whatever we want so I'm like alright
don't care anymore just tell me when
it's done about the blog there's a video
of a cat that tried to make it like like
she try to launch over two counters was
it to the that song sale yes
[Laughter]
but it's like the other sell right it's
like electric rock then we're a cat and
a duck are friends and they hug this
[ __ ] cute there's a trend going on
tick tock where you try to put your pets
ears in a ponytail holder
this woman she goes Anna put it in a bun
and so everyone does it when dogs do it
it's cute when they try to do it to cats
every single cat has the same response
to having their ears pinned into a
ponytail holder where they all are just
like so you capture all of you about
politics to take all too seriously
let the ear thing be on your head don't
be just don't freak out cool dogs are if
only people could be more like dogs
about all I still like going to my dogs
and making his eyes look more Chinese
people I quote these are Chinese
Shepherds me just at first Chinese
retrievers yeah I like looking at baby
videos like there's this one that I
recently came across I was like oh my
god it's too [ __ ] cute but is this
like a head scratcher I went on top of
his bald baby he was
looks like it adorable like the answer
should I enjoy do you remember in middle
school when chicks thought that if you
if you put your fingers on the guy's
knee and you just went like this a gay
man instant boner
no it wasn't for boner what do you mean
I thought was friends I never heard that
is it wrong
it didn't [ __ ] work we did it on each
other - like good yeah I'm like you wish
this gave me about it I don't think
that's its act Akash yeah it's like when
I go going on a treasure hunt x marks
the spot
alright oh you like that I do like that
boner
yeah that's just the easy way to get
laid like worked every time I think that
the girls I want got some weird sex
misconception I think I thought that
that was supposed to that the girls
thought it was just because you have
boners anyone ever ask you straight up
did you get a boner I think so nah I
think honestly so yeah then they
misunderstood maybe you really like - oh
that could be anyway what else I skip
buttons would you guys wish you could
have
skip intro they finally did it thank God
cuz house of cards intro was six and a
half minutes long I'm like brother I
started like teleporting through from my
current day it's a medieval times let me
tell you not when you binge watch it for
24 hours good like oh who is everybody
again like it's a refresher you see all
the buildings spinning around
yeah but the buildings all look like
that that's the problem with I have with
it or if we could skip the credits to
get to the last part on the HBO shows so
we can see like the ending you like at
the tail end of the episode the button
like the inside the episode or whatever
yeah I'm gonna give you a little bit
behind the scenes all Sark's pretty
tired you just starts and then it shows
you the target with like the four things
that happen
yeah I think so how it works I just
started that or the reverse yeah I wish
I had it in life like where I'm like
okay now I have to work out but I don't
want to work out and then I just skip to
the part where after I work out I feel
good yeah quick yes oh yeah I was
thinking I'd love be like she's get
being pregnant and having the childbirth
and he'll you're having oh yeah yeah
yeah I'm like cool I you came out of me
sort of dude how come he can't like grow
it in a shopping cart next to you a
shopping cart is what of something ball
boy yeah with wheels
boy we don't have the ability to [ __ ]
grow a little human being and like a
like a thing that's outside what they
did already for a sheep that's called
the ICU right no they brought the baby
outside of the mom no that's not growing
oh they'll grow it right I think it's a
process to like help overpopulation like
because we'd all be having too many kids
oh you think so if there's if it didn't
hurt
[Music]
you